today we're going to talk about
considerations for human robot
collaboration
so i direct the assistive robotics and
manipulation laboratory the arm lab
where our mission is to develop
assistive robotics uh that are
intelligent assistive collaborative and
are able to improve human life
the main area of our focus covers
robotic assistance which you can think
of as external agents that are going to
work alongside a person
intelligent wearables these are robots
that are attached to a person that are
helping them to perform a task and
require situational awareness
and then connected devices so these
might be more passive but still require
a situational awareness in order to
anticipate the service needs
for the people that you're wanting to
work with
and all the problems that we have we
have this similar paradigm where the
robot needs to be aware of itself
the complexity of the task is trying to
complete as well as perhaps the human or
other agent
that's in the loop that it has to
collaborate with
i'm very fortunate to be working with
many amazing amazing
phd and master students and i'll
fortunately be able to highlight some of
their work today
so if we think about uh the path of
robotics and how it's evolved over the
past few decades we can see that um
collaborative robotics really stands to
be one of the pinnacle points um that
robotics has to offer
if you go back to like the 80s through
the 2000s
automation was really big we had these
you know robots that were able to do
these amazing things they had a lot of
power um and the goal was if you could
set up you know your system such that
they could do a repetitive task very
well you could complete some of these
tasks efficiently with these types of
systems
but then we realized that there was more
to be had here if we could introduce
this ability for our robot to operate in
environments that were less certain
right so could you operate in a space
with still a degree of precision and
repeatability even when um things
weren't carefully
uh uh set up for you as it was on the
for instance on the manufacturing floor
so we see this introduction in this this
rise of autonomy
then uh we had this big push towards
swarm robotics so these are multiple
robots that work together
often you know in these really big
groups you know there might be some
central oracle that's telling all of the
agents what to do and yet we're able to
do these really amazing things
and then you have these decentralized
systems as the functionality increases
and the numbers increase in the
physical scale and distance increase it
becomes important that each one of these
systems actually have if you will a mind
of its own
and yet still be able to collaborate
with robots in its vicinity and operate
toward a larger objective of the uh of
this of the system and then finally we
have this this augmentation so
what if the
other agent that you're working with is
not for instance another robot that you
can digitally communicate with what if
it's a person
how can you take everything from
automation to autonomy to the ability to
work in teams
and now allow that collaborator to be
robot or human
so uh to give an idea of some of the
things that we've been thinking about in
this kind of space we have you know
considerations you could imagine and
this is just a subset of collaborative
ideas you could uh could think of this
as some that were of interest to us in
the arm lab
how could robots perhaps carry objects
with human counterparts
could you have wearable sensors for
instance that could predict where a
person wants to go and if there is a
risk of falling
perhaps alert them or if it's integrated
with a lower limb exoskeleton actually
be an input for control
how can a robot work with a human to a
understand a complex task that you want
the robot to complete
such as efficient learning from
demonstration and then if the robot's
working with a person how can that robot
be super efficient
in that process with the human
if we think about
the space of prosthetics
is there value to having a robotic
system that has a degree of autonomy
when it works with um a human
counterpart in order to complete a
complex task that the person may
otherwise not be able to do on their own
what does this mean in the space of
autonomy to have a robot that
understands the environment and yet um
wants to share that autonomy with the
person
particularly if you think at levels four
and five where you're not completely
handing over control to the robot maybe
there's a need for transition what does
shared autonomy look like and how can
that be collaborative
you can even imagine this an extended
scenario such as you know leveraging
these types of tools to improve the
ability to
even perform interpretations such as you
know asl how can you pull all of these
informations from a person such as their
facial expressions in addition to some
of their gestures and think of that
sequentially in that interpretation
many of these ideas have been of
interest to us over the last few years
so today i want to ask three primary
questions one
what makes an effective collaborator
two
what tools do we have and what do we
need to make robots effective
collaborators
and three
what must be considered for human robot
teams
so let's start with what makes an
effective collaborator
so if we kind of think about how robots
collaborate with each other this sort of
robot robot collaboration scenario we
can really look at um perhaps even
centralized or decentralized control
where these robots are actually able to
communicate via digital communication
and so here this is a swarm of
quadrotors that are flying in unison in
this figure eight you have two
perspectives of them um and they're
actually able to collaborate and they
share this information at some base
station some oracle
you can imagine um scaling this up and
if you do then consensus becomes very
important such that desired behavior
um of each agent
is prescribed or they know or they're
told what they need to do in order to
be
successful
so this is how you know robots can
effectively work together then we have
really great demonstrations of this
collaboration but if we can think about
what could be
perhaps it would be a good idea to look
at how humans
or biological agents
work together and maybe we can have some
motivation from that kind of
uh interaction so if you look at these
sort of
biological coordination abilities and
strategies
we see that biological agent team
agent teams are especially good with
coordination even without
digital communication
and so the question we can ask here is
what makes an effective team
you know if you if you observe this
scenario here there's clearly not a lot
of communication and yet
they're able to actually coordinate in
an extremely high level
even beating out for instance this other
team to make this point
so some of the uh the goals that we need
in order to have an effective team
include
shared goals or objectives among
teammates
if we take this scenario right are they
both intending on making the basket are
they both going to the same side of the
court
is there the ability to model teammates
uh for behavior prediction
even if we share the same goal we want
to make the basket for instance
if you know your teammate is unable to
perform in a particular athletic way
then that should actually change your
behavior and how you expect to interact
with them
and then finally uh the ability to plan
given your personal and teammates roles
right so given the shared objective
given an understanding of the
policy if you will or the ability of
your teammates how can you leverage that
to roll out and plan what actions you
should take that will benefit the entire
team
and so the question is right if these
are the objectives how could this be
achieved particularly if we think about
cases where you know these biological
agents are able to perform at a high
level with limited communication
modalities such as audio vision
and tactile so if you think about
you know for instance the
audio uh
method of communication this allows for
high specificity right you know i'm
talking to you i'm describing this
process to you
the trouble is it could be slow right so
it's not necessarily operation tempo
and it's subject to um you know the
sequential speaking listening that might
be required especially when you want to
do something
quickly that requires a lot of high
coordination
vision on the other hand um can be done
mutually and information exchange can be
very fast and in fact very detailed as i
would argue this video you see here of
these uh
i think they're border collies actually
forcing these ducks into this ring
you know they're taking action about
where they're placing themselves
relative to
the the ducks in order to drive them to
the target but they also have to take
into account where their teammate is
and leverage their position relative to
that teammate's position
in their motion in order to coordinate
that motion
you know for instance here of the ducks
and so here there's this visual
communication that's allowing for that
op tempo
operation and collaboration
in fact you can imagine even on the on a
completely different scale if you think
about for instance even how insects like
bees are able to communicate very
complex concepts about where for
instance food might be again you have
this notion of communication through
um visual demonstration
um to a teammate
and then you can have the uh the tactile
side right and so if you think about
touch our forces for communication this
can also be extremely fast
but of course you have this sort of
proximity requirement
so here you have an individual who's
visually impaired and yet you know at
the same up tempo that the game is
actually occurring his their friend is
able to actually communicate to them the
state of the game and you know they're
able to celebrate in real time with that
very quick tactile
communication
if we think about the key features of
teamwork i would argue there's two main
paradigms we need to think about on the
one side we have
role understanding so
you know just if you look go back to the
border collies or you know any one of
these other scenarios even the
basketball game how do you actually
collaborate with a person what is your
role
that is required in order to achieve
your target
is it unique you know given the
particular task that you're trying to
complete
and then finally if we try to think
about what kind of conditions we need to
think about in order for
ages to work together we might have to
develop some notation for our thinking
in terms of trust between these agents
and kind of going back to what we talked
about in terms of the agreed objectives
and being able to
understand what another teammate is able
to do in order to then roll out a plan
to collaborate
if we take those two top elements right
then we could argue that a condition for
trust the condition for collaboration
and taking action that you believe
will lead to the betterment of the goals
of the entire team would include a
having an agreed objective with the
teammates that you're working with
and then having a behavioral model of
your teammates
i mean if you have these two things if
you know that you're trying to achieve
the same thing and you have a good idea
of their
um policy and their capabilities then
you can actually leverage this
information to work effectively together
and so
a very simple toy example of this could
be you know uh this strategy on whether
or not for instance this red car will
change lanes here
you know before uh red trusts blue it
has to first agree
that it believes blue does not want to
collide that's an objective but then you
know even if blue clearly didn't want to
collide if you know b if the blues
breaks are not that great
that's the control authority part of
that paradigm so even if the objective
was
you know uh parallel
does the behavioral model does the
control ability match
that objective right and if it does if
blue is able to maintain that velocity
or break um as necessary then what you
can imagine um doing is having a
scenario where red can therefore trust
that it's safe
for instance to merge in front of blue
so you know if we think about what are
the natural limitations you know of
biological teams
we see that you know there are instances
where there's a limited communication
modality you know limited dexterity and
strength to weight ratio
and possibly limited perception
and if we think about how these
biological teams are actually able to
overcome these challenges
we see that they really leverage the
understanding of the role given the team
in task
they
model the task and they model their
teammates
so
we see these attributes so the question
is within the space of robotics you know
what tools do we have within robotics to
make these robots
effective collaborators
so um i will argue there's three main uh
areas of robotics that you know we can
really focus on is providing a lot of
the tools underlying tools for us to
complete this one is
proprioception and control
do you know where you are and do you
have the ability to control yourself
right
do you have the ability to perceive your
environment
either visually
or through touch as being perhaps
primary methods to do
that do you have the ability to plan and
characterize and model
what you see
the other agents in your environment and
yourself and how they all work together
in order to achieve target behavior for
the team
so jumping first into this sort of
proprioception and control and just you
know for those who are unfamiliar a
quick overview of what you know is
present you know you have forward
kinematics let's say i have a robot that
has joints clearly we're able to have
encoders we're able to have torque you
know position velocity control
we're able to model our internal
dynamics
right um and which will allow us to
actually achieve the motions that we
would want to
perform
on the side of this sort of planning for
your motion right if you have many
degrees of freedom you know motion
planners have been around for quite a
while the more degrees of freedom you
have the state of the art
is either to use methods like
sample-based planners to plan a near
environment i mean even more recently
there actually have been really cool
demonstrations of using neural networks
particularly rl algorithms that have
actually learned how to map
some desired motion to what the state
should actually do to do things really
quickly there's one really cool video
out there where a particular arm is
actually able to catch a flying object
based on an rl algorithm that was
actually trained
to understand the kinematics of the arm
and it could catch an object in real
time
and then you have the ability of for
uh control right so if i'm actually
touching my environment can i actually
exert or control the amount of force
that i'm using to interact with my
environment
expanding a bit on that ability to
contact your environment you know
there's two main paradigms you might uh
end up thinking about you have you know
the ability to control you know the
amount of stiffness that you apply on
the environment or you can actually
control the amount of admittance that
you accept from your environment
in a sort of impedance controller you're
setting an objective that you want the
arm to follow however you actually have
the ability to modulate the stiffness of
your system to respond to that external
input or perturbation
on the emittance side perhaps again you
have an objective you want to follow but
if there's an external disturbance you
allow yourself to take that disturbance
in a meaningful way and this is not only
in the case of uh perhaps you know hand
manipulation but even this plays a
really big wall a role
in robots that are even you know walking
in particular environment so you might
find yourself using an emittance
controller for a walking robot so that
based on where it puts its feet down
right it doesn't try to jam through
which would actually cause imbalance but
reacts to the different terrain that it
touches
by allowing that admittance in contact
and so these two paradigms can be very
useful depending on what your task is
and you would you know make that
decision based on your objective
on the side of perception right we've
seen many many amazing advances
in different tools like
cnns that allow us to extract key
information from visual data
we of course have laser rangefinders
right that are able to detect uh you
know objects at a distance and give us a
really high fidelity point cloud or even
up close
here i think this is with an intel
realsense our picoflex sensor excuse me
that's observing this person's face
and then we have the onset of even
tactile sensors here shown
uh an early version of gel site versus
a piezo uh i think resistive material
that allows you to feel contact
so
all of these um uh are extremely
important and we've seen a lot of really
cool
um you know use cases of these
particularly in the camera sensing and
the laser rangefinder integration for
you know estimating you know the system
state but if we want to think about the
role that collaborative robots could
eventually play in our future we perhaps
want them for instance in our homes
in assisted care living facilities
possibly in the warehouse doing small
assembly and so i would argue that one
of the things that still needs a lot of
work is actually this space over here
this tactile sensing
that's the catalyst if we had a robot
that could feel
you know closer to the way a human could
feel right and really bridge that gap i
think would open up a lot of really cool
avenues for research
to address these different areas
and so while we've been able to already
make a lot of progress in these other
spaces i think this is actually one of
the key barriers that is still
holding us back to wide acceptance of
robotics in everyday life
so let's think about where we would like
to be so this is a a great motivating uh
video from open ai
where um you know they're able to
actually solve this rubric's cube with
one hand
what you don't see behind the curtain
is in fact you know cameras that are
externally looking at the hand and all
of the hours of rl that was trained uh
used in order to provide this feedback
additionally while this sensor does have
the attributes of
having basic contact sensing
if i recall correctly that wasn't
extremely leveraged or extremely useful
in terms of that planning and when you
want to actually move to a new object
this can actually be very challenging
so we kind of think about that modular
aspect of touch right here's where we
want to be and we want to be able to
actually you know apply this to any new
task very quickly
right what do we need to think about
well let's zoom in a little bit and
focus on
those points of contact and what we can
think about there
so if we look at you know where we are
this is um you know
this work on this uh gel slim sensor so
what you see here is you have a camera
that's inside of this uh fingertip
it reflects off of a mirror and observes
through a transparent gel the deflection
of the boundary
and that uh the interface of one of
these sensors is what you end up seeing
there on the top
left when it plays
now these markers have been uh placed on
here at a discrete
step and when you actually form when you
actually contact an object it causes
deformation
and that deformation can be tracked
through optical flow or you know image
comparison and this actually shows you
the stresses that have been applied on
the face of that object
and so with this you can have some
notion of displacement of the uh of the
hand and then this can actually allow
you to think about right in fact you
know what types of forces are actually
being applied
and the challenge here becomes you know
really how can you calibrate these
systems right that's still an open
question calibrating these really well
and at high resolution
so if we dig a little bit deeper into
the types of tactile sensors that are
available and what can be done currently
you know you have um you know this
classic biotech sensor here
that gives you a smaller resolution than
you know perhaps the vision based sensor
but extremely reliable
and gives you a few points of contact
you have
sensors such as the digit which are 2d
shaped vision based sensors so you can
see that the fingers themselves are flat
but this is really easy to integrate
with some
nice hands and you can actually have
that effect if you can get the object
between those fingers in that flat
region
you have more curved fingers so here
we'll call it like 2.5 d
you know the sensor like bubble soft so
it um uses like pneumatic pressure to
expand inside of this uh finger so it's
kind of like a balloon and then they uh
use
a time-of-flight sensor that's inside of
the hand to track
the deformation of you know points on
that surface as it touches an object
and then you have bringing this all
together on the far end how do you
shrink this compactness
this is the omni omnitech sensor
developed at berkeley which uses a set
of micro cameras that actually look
through at particular sub regions
of the finger and are able to then track
those sub-region deformations
by treating them relatively flat by you
know zooming in on those particular
areas
of the of the finger
so you know in the arm lab we said you
know these are all fantastic um but you
know where is there space to grow here
you know is the perfect finger out there
right and so we began to think about
what you know that finger might look
like and within that space we asked
ourselves from a design
perspective can we leverage
anthropomorphic inspiration in a curved
fingertip capable of deforming
and sensing friction as well
from a modeling perspective
can we efficiently model a continuous
curved fingertip with high resolution
that allows us to have this in a
computationally tractable way
and characterize stable grasps
and this is a note that actually means
you know if we're able to achieve this
unlike a lot of the approaches which use
end to end learning if you have this
high resolution image of your points of
contact and you're trying to map this
all the way back to small joints that
you should this is a huge space
and adaptability can be a real challenge
when you want to change from one object
to another so if you modulate modularize
your network and you're able to say you
know i can characterize even with a
machine learning model right what a
stable grasp is then can i actually use
that
as a sub module perhaps in
an rl framework to allow me to do more
complex manipulation strategies
and then that's what comes next the
motion planning how do you leverage
those models that design
in order to do efficient continuous
modeling of your fingertips to plan
multi-finger grasps
for in-hand manipulations
so toward that objective um the arm lab
has developed
this new sensor we're calling densetact
um and it has uh this particular form so
currently it's this very hemispherical
sensor
that's relatively cheap to make less
than a hundred dollars and most of that
comes from the camera itself
and we have leds that illuminate the
interior of this uh sensor
and then we have a coated gel on the end
so that when you touch this you can
actually track the deformation
interior so this first version of the
sensor is really good
at sensing shape
now one of the key benefits here let me
see if this video will play
one of the key benefits here to think
about
right is how we can actually um
calibrate such a system how can that
calibration
be achieved and so um in a paper that
was recently accepted you know our
objective here is to say well you know
if you actually look at many different
modalities of calibration including
perhaps having external sensors like
time-of-flight sensors that look at your
sensor
externally this can actually be very
challenging right to actually
say you know how much on the on the
order of millimeters submillimeters
was this deformation of my sensor
everywhere that's extremely challenging
so our approach was to actually say what
if we pressed our sensor into
known shapes that itself you know if you
3d print these you know have an
associated error that comes from the 3d
printer
and then you have the gift of you know
when you look through this
camera you can actually see the high
resolution image that's generated
when you actually perform
that deformation
and because you're pressing into these
known shapes
now you know where the position is
everywhere at your points of contact
and so now you actually have this really
nice supervised data set
images correlated with a you know a
shape that you know everywhere
and now you can actually perform
learning you know through a sort of auto
encoding framework with skip connections
to say
you know how can i actually map my image
to an output radial depth map using ray
tracing where i'm actually using my loss
function coming from
uh you know a known shape that i pressed
into
allowing me to have this really high
resolution
uh a
calibrated
touch
and so now we actually have this ability
to actually model
this at a very high level
and because we were able to calibrate
this really three-dimensional curve
sensor at this high level now we can ask
a lot of interesting questions that you
can't really get otherwise and even have
an outcome of
you know this point cloud you see on the
far
right hand side
and so you know kind of thinking about
these kind of use cases you know there's
a lot of different spaces uh to expand
this now that you actually have
this calibrated high resolution
uh point cloud of your of your surface
what can you do you know and so you know
to that end we're actually doing work
and exploration seeing how we can
combine
vision
and touch together to for instance you
know improve nerfs neural radiance
fields
in order to better represent you know
objects that you're exploring
you can think about you know in the
second generation of these sensors which
i'll show on the next slide you know if
you can actually then add an addition to
the uh this is a screw and then this is
the point cloud of the screw bring
preston you're seeing here in the
uh top corner here if you then take to
the next step and you say okay you know
if i can get forces as well
shown here so this is um
the generation 1.5 we're actually a
little bit better than this now with
generation 1.5 you know put on to
you know the allegro hand you can still
begin to track these forces so
you know here in this first column uh
on the right hand side
you know you have the undeformed
sensor and you're pressing into
this a penny here and if you go on that
normal side as you push more
you can see this optical flow data
showing the expansion
in this case
for shear you can see the shear
directions
and for torsion you can see that
torsional
effect coming and so again you could say
okay well how does this really differ
for instance from
you know some of the methods of you know
like gel site well the real takeaway
that we're trying to really approach
here is to say well
you know if you just had the points
right you can actually have an aliasing
effect so if i produce a shear with like
the gel site gel slim version
you know and there's too much distortion
then after a particular amount there's
aliasing that can be uh in effect if you
keep track of that you know over time
then you can kind of avoid that by you
know performing some sort of integration
but that produces more model overhead um
for you to complete that
even if you were to for instance have
like you know x's you know even for like
rotation
you know simple you know crosses would
still
um produce a degree of aliasing even
angular you know from some angular
deformation so the question we're
thinking about in the from the pattern
side is can you generate a pattern that
in a small enough resolution could
actually be robust
to extreme deformation
right and that could be both from shear
or torsion
and if that's possible right this gives
you a completely different
paradigm in terms of what you can then
come back and say can i calibrate this
at a super
you know at a higher level of cal of
contact
where i can actually say more about
those points you know in between the
measurements that i'm able to make and
so there's two parts there on the design
side there's how can we develop a
pattern
that allows us to have this
higher resolution for our deformation
and then on the second side it's how do
you calibrate the highest resolution
sensor in the world right you know this
is literally you know more points of
contact per area than you know any high
resolution sensor that exists you know
and so our approach to this
which you'll see more coming up in the
few months to come is to really say well
can we actually uh begin to think about
um the fact that you know if we were
able to use
uh meta learning right can we actually
look at you know modeling this in
simulation to actually use a methods
like a gaussian process to say
you know if i contact this particular
area and i'm able to actually measure
these particular points you know with an
actual real sensor that i'm calibrating
with if i can use a gaussian process
that can capture
the material properties right and also
have a notion of uncertainty in the
points that i'm not measuring
and can i actually use that
that metal learned model that's trained
in simulation to then come to the real
world with a real sensor that is at a
lower resolution than the sensor i have
and then use a gaussian process with the
real points of contact the same at the
points that i'm measuring i'm very
confident
feed that back you know through your
error mse error on your image to say
you know did you predict for instance
the stress the correct stress
at this point and where you're uncertain
you know then use that as a waiting
factor for your error as you backprop
that through your network and predicting
uh what you're where you're in contact
and so with that not only do you have
the ability to say
you know i'm training this
high resolution sensor with a few points
of contact and using a gaussian process
to interpolate in between but that
gaussian process is also informed by
the mechanics of the material that i'm
touching and the uncertainty allows me
to
inform my network that if there are
points far from the points that are
actually in contact you should ignore
that at that particular time
and so you know in in the few months to
come you'll see some exciting work in
that space that allows us to calibrate
this at
a higher level
once that's achieved we can then say you
know okay uh
i have all of this calibrated force
wrench you know all my sensors and if
i'm touching an object at multiple
points of contact
right what does this tell me about my
grasp stability
right and so you know if you kind of
look back into the literature and
mechanical engineering like in the 90s
you know they brought up this notion of
like uh
you know you had friction cones which is
to say i push in with a normal force
you know into a plane and there's
friction how much friction can i reject
in any direction if it's if it's a a a
isotropic material then no matter which
direction you're you're
pushing in the friction is the same in
that surface
and if i have multiple points of contact
then i can you know resist motion from
the normal force that i'm applying and
the friction forces that can stop that
motion when i'm holding an object
and so if you have point contacts this
actually creates
a polytope in which what we call the
wrench space
so if you think about you know just
forces for now no moments if you have
the three axis for the forces and i'm
i'm able to reject forces in any
direction
this creates a polytope that says if you
apply a force on this object like
gravity
right as long as it's inside of this
polytope you can reject
those forces and keep the object in
place and stable
and you can extend that notion to you
know the moment space
as well and that becomes a six
dimensional space for your wrench right
x y z and then moments about the x y and
z axis
and more points of contact you have the
more complex that polytope becomes
well now we have soft fingers
so now it's not just point contacts it's
these continuous contacts
instead of thinking polytope we should
now start thinking manifold right and so
what does that look like and if we have
this this notion of manifold that comes
from
perhaps a learned model instead of like
an fem sort of approach to this so it
can be calculated more quickly
how could such a model for a point for a
series of contacts in hand grasp
be actually leveraged in an rl framework
that's informed by that so if i want to
transition an object in my hand you know
as i think about the multi points of
contact as i manipulated can my planner
have knowledge of that
six dimensional manifold of grass
stability and plan in her
you know multi-contacts and motion of
the fingers that keeps the
object in the manifold of grass
stability between the contacts that i
make
more fun stuff coming later this year
and so yeah that can then inform
multi-grasps and narrow planners that
could leverage such a model
shifting little gears a little bit here
to intelligence
right you know if we consider a lot of
the tools that can be good for
predicting behavior or actions of the
other
often you know you find yourself in a
need to be able to predict the
trajectory of what your
teammate is actually doing
and within this kind of our structure
you can think about ontological models
which you know again postulate some
underlying structure
or you can think of uh data-driven
approaches
um and this is what you've uh has been
very popular in the literature is
generative approaches to try and model
the uh the behavior and trust
and of agents that you're collaborating
with are trying to predict
and then tying this back to you know
robotic consensus and swarm behavior you
know we see that you know common
algorithms for cooperation can be
categorized as
a having an oracle you know a single
entity that's telling all the others
what to do
you could have a shared plan where all
agents act independently towards some
predetermined goal
and then you can even have consensus
through some type of voting
system
okay
so we've kind of discussed some of the
tools that we have in terms of
you know proprioception and control
uh perception external perception right
and intelligence so
you know what must be considered for a
human and effective human robot team
so if we think about that i would argue
that some of the key challenges for
human robot teams you know really come
down to again to that digital
communication
conversation
what do robots need to be effective
teammates for humans
i would argue need the ability to uh
model complex tasks
the ability to interpret and manipulate
environments configured for humans
and
the ability to model teammates actions
and roles
so what we're going to do is look at
some examples now
in two main categories one being
wearables
that effectively augment the human that
they're supposed to work with
we'll look at some that are designed to
substitute an ability of the human some
that are designed to enhance
the ability of a human and then we'll
look at you know a more formal sort of
collaborator if you will an external
collaborator that serves as sort of a
human partner some examples in the arm
lab that kind of look at that so at this
point i'm going to kind of transition to
some of our work that we've been working
on over the past few years and kind of
give an outline of you know what we've
been looking at in these um in these
spaces
so starting with you know an ability
substituting device right
particularly for wearables you know the
question we have to ask ourselves
is what part of the human being is being
augmented or substituted
and then is the robot augmentation
functionally adequate
you know does the presence of the robot
feel natural
and easy to use
so this uh
motivates well one of our projects
called the intelligent prosthetic arm
project
it's motivated if you think about
individuals who have shoulder
disarticulation
here this individual has a
disarticulation on both sides
completing tasks with body power devices
is possible but very challenging
particularly as the complexity of the
task increases
from a dexterity standpoint
and so
the question we ask is you know if you
have
um a prosthetic that is endowed with
robotic autonomy
could it actually be informed by the
complexity of the task that you're
trying to complete as well as whatever
possibly limited input you're able to
accept from the human
can it interact with the human
and then through those modalities
actually give the person a sense of
agency so they can complete a task
with a level of dexterity that they
would have otherwise not been able to
accomplish
now if you're familiar with the space
you might be aware that there are you
know devices that exist out there like
the luke arm or mpl right and a lot of
these are you know driven directly
complete control through like emgs
electromyography you know or bci brain
computer interfaces
in order to achieve that control but the
challenge with all of these is you know
no matter how deep how deep you go
usually you're still dealing with an
under actuated problem
which means given the high degrees of
freedom you want to control in the arm
the human is unable to provide the
number of inputs independent inputs that
match that output
and even as you get closer and you
continue to ask more and more from the
human you actually end up sometimes
negatively affecting the human with
cognitive load they've got to remember
what the new mapping is everywhere and
that can be
really challenging now of course they
adapt and learn over a long time but
that can actually be a barrier for the
use of the device if you then couple
that with things like its weight
you know and uncomfortability and things
like that
and so what you see here um is
the first step for us trying to move
toward that goal
and what we've actually uh done here uh
my student shivani gupta samara you can
see we're actually simulating uh an arm
inside of a hololens 2.
and so you actually see this simulated
arm here and i'll get into a little bit
later some of the tasks that we want to
start off with which allows us to first
just jump over the hardware questions
and allow our system to perceive the
environment allow our system to actuate
virtually and then we can really focus
on the intelligence how can we really
get information from the human
to perform the task be it through
emgs eegs or with our collaborators even
eclg
you know to actually get input from the
human to do these complex tasks
and today i'm going to really cover just
the cases when the robot knows the task
but we're even interested in looking
into solving problems about
cases when the robot doesn't know a task
how do you perform learning from
demonstration
you know when there is no demonstrator
and you don't have arms to demonstrate
how can that be achieved and this is
this is you know the case what we're
looking at and we realize that augmented
reality again can play a really big role
in giving you a sort of a play pin to
query the human for demonstrations
and even visually demonstrate to the
human what you understand
the domain of acceptable performances to
be and if that's validated
allow the uh robot to then execute you
know in a very efficient manner
so kind of expanding on this a little
bit more uh if you think about an
able-bodied person here you know they're
able to uh you know plan control actuate
themselves their body responds
and they're able to perceive that as
they're performing some tasks on the
environment
if you imagine having a powered
prosthesis
then they're going to be providing some
input via emg or bci to that system
right in order to for it to actuate and
perform some tasks in the world and
unless there was some surgery that
actually mapped some of their nerves for
feedback which has been done
then usually um they have to perceive
themselves
you know what has actually occurred in
their environment
then you can imagine having some robotic
systems that actually have a degree of
perception as well
so maybe there's not an extreme amount
of you know internal intelligence but
maybe if you touch something hot
you know it can withdraw from something
hot and give you some very basic
low-level controllability
and then finally you know you have what
we're aiming for here which is the
intelligent power prosthesis
it has the ability to plan the ability
to act the ability to sense and at the
same time take information and provide
information
to the human that it's working with so
that you have
essentially two minds and one goal
so
you know one of the key enabling
technologies here i kind of alluded to
is augmented reality and i think you
know while it's traditionally been you
know thought of a lot in terms of the
gaming space i think it has a whole lot
to offer and you know essential utility
and this is a perfect example of that
utility
so things you can get with like
information you can get from
systems like hololens 2
you know include the gaze from the
person you can actually track where
they're looking
in their environment
and of course you're able to actually
project in the augmented reality case
objects into their real environment that
look hyper-realistic
and that interfacing if done well can
actually be a very nice way for the
robot to get information from the person
in terms of attention as well as provide
cues and questions to the person and
feedback
based on what the robot wants to do
without running the risk of actually
acting on the environment
at a given time
so as a kind of example here you have
this
you know consider this activity of daily
living and feeding yourself so you can
think of this in terms of a state
machine
and if for instance i treat the gays as
this circle and uh plus sign here
you know if the question initially was
do you want to actually feed yourself
or you know take a drink there's no uh
fluid in the cup so probably you can't
manipulate the cup yet until you've
actually you know filled it uh then gaze
could actually be a really good
indicator for instance on you know the
fact that you might want to interact
with the pitcher first
in order to you know fill your cup
once you're filling your cup perhaps you
know to provide agency if you don't want
the robot to just passively do stuff you
want to feel like you're in control
perhaps some other device like an amg
could actually inform the device to
continue the process
but maybe the gaze is not as important
at that instance when you're knowing
what you know exactly what the task is
you can provide that agency you know by
only asking for much lower degrees of
freedom input from the person to
complete that task like
complete the pour
and then you could have potentially a
choice do you want to actually want to
go from the picture to feeding yourself
or perhaps taking a drink again perhaps
gays can then play another significant
role in helping you make that decision
and then perhaps you know there's too
much cognition involved in actually
determining where on the plate you want
to scoop maybe autonomy again can play a
nice role here and actually helping the
person and then you know emg again can
be a big help in that reduced degree of
freedom in providing agency to the
person while they complete the task
so we want to kind of think of this sort
of uh idea mathematically right then
let's kind of think of this you know in
this uh type of uh framework right what
what information do we have
so if we uh if we think of here uh you
know our state you know as s
our gaze vector as g perhaps some other
input like emg as e and some desired
robot action is a
we can even develop a very simplistic
model
for thinking about
what action should the robot do
conditioned on the state of the task
and the available input from the human
and so
you know steps to solving this would
first be can you actually model the
human's behavior
if you knew what the human was trying to
do what action it was and you knew the
state of the system
right can you actually model what you'd
expect them to do where do you expect
them to look
what you'd expect them to to fire in
order to achieve that
and then you can actually you know more
abstractly say
given a particular state of the system
what makes sense contextually right what
is the action that you would do
conditioned on the state of the
environment at a given time
and then you know you could actually you
know
nicely frame this even in terms of bayes
rule to help you arrive at a best
estimate or a probability distribution
about what you think the person would
want to complete
and so even solving that um you know
such a system here allows you to
characterize the human behavior model
and intent model to then predict what
action you think you should take
conditioned on what the human
information the human provided to you
and the state of the task and
environment
some people like to visualize this you
know graphically so kind of thinking of
it in that fashion again imagine this
example where you're trying to determine
what the human wants to do here do they
want to manipulate this cup that might
be empty initially
or this pitcher which might have some
fluid in it initially that you might
want to pour to then drink from this cup
so
based on that simple task understanding
if you know the cup is empty you
perceive that it's 17 and the picture
was full you might have some initial
distribution here think of this this
manifold as a probability distribution
that is more likely you might want to
interact with this pitcher at this
standpoint just because from task
understanding that's what makes perhaps
the most sense
but you don't know maybe the person did
want to actually grab the cup and you
know place it somewhere else so what
other information could you pull from
the
person perhaps you have some gays
you know of the person that intersects
the table and you could think of that
itself as actually producing a
probability distribution in that
environment around the known tasks that
you could be
completing and then of course perhaps
you have some input via from emg or some
bci that's driving at a low dimensional
state that you want to take some action
to begin with
on your environment
and perhaps if you condition all of
these things together this can actually
allow you to have both an intent model
and a behavioral model
to help you determine you know what
action makes the most sense at that time
to complete
and what's really cool is you can kind
of decouple it if you frame it in this
way you can kind of decouple the notion
of you know what makes sense in terms of
a task
right what actions would you do in terms
of a task which would in fact allow you
to collect a lot of data even from
people who don't necessarily need the
device
to understand this relationship for all
the different task spaces that you could
have
and then separately you could actually
train the sort of calibration routine if
i specify to the user
here's the state and we want you to
complete this action
i can calibrate this to you this is the
calibration phase which is even done for
conventional prosthesis
right in order to understand what the
mapping is for the person to complete
a specified task
as a first step to trying to complete
this
and let's see if this video is playing
yes fantastic you know uh we're working
on a work right now where we say well
what if we actually do this in terms of
a chess game so imagine you know you
have this virtual arm a virtual chess
board and you're trying to complete this
uh game of virtual chess
you could actually ex take you know the
state of the environment to actually be
the state of the game
right and say you know given this
particular game what would be the likely
strategy to maximize points that can
give you indication indicator of p of
action conditioned on the state
and then you could take some input from
the emg you could take some input from
the gaze and then use that to inform
you about which piece the person would
probably likely try to move
and then validate for our method you
know does this actually for instance
reduce cognitive load
and so the end goal here while we might
be having some fun with checkers right
now the end goal would ultimately be to
then apply this at a higher level to
some of these
more complex tasks such as activities of
daily living
with the objective again being that you
know if we implement this method right
would our system actually be do uh give
the ability to this uh to the person
to a you know be more intuitive would it
actually be easier to learn
how to perform the task better the
learning rate could that be sharper and
then you know if we have this ability to
integrate autonomy then unlike
body-powered devices or just simple you
know electric devices that have to be
completely controlled by the person can
just the overall functionality of the
system
be at a higher level right and so you
know our goal is to actually increase
both of these things can we increase the
learning rate
right and then can the person actually
perform at a higher level once that
maximum learning uh if you will is
achieved
so kind of transitioning now from an
ability substituting device perhaps to
an ability enhancing device
uh you can think here um about uh you
know ones that improve the sensory
feedback concerning the world
so one of our leading projects here is
actually a fall prevention sensor that
we've um developed in our lab that will
ultimately we think also be useful for
lower limb exoskeleton path prediction
uh and control
so as a first step here you know we
realized that you know uh one of the
leading causes of fatal and non-fatal
injuries for older adults can be falling
and so you know if you had a device that
could actually predict in the next few
seconds that you were at high risk of
falling
and it was able to alert you would that
actually possibly reduce that risk and
if so
you know perhaps you know reduce the
number of um
you know first steps that are leading to
these unfortunate cases
right um and then of course the question
is you know can we actually have a
system that you know people would want
to wear
at the same time can it have this really
cool robotic functionality at the same
time
perform at this level
and so our architecture is to say you
know if we actually
have an onboard sensor that is actually
able to see the environment
and
actually collect odometry or your path
right from an onboard imu and
information about the uh the environment
can you actually use that
in for instance like an rnn or gru
structure to then say
i'm i see the sequence of where you went
from your odometry and i'm able to see
your surroundings can i use that
information to predict
perhaps a multimodal distribution about
where you will go
and can i have some notion of how stable
you will be in that path that you'll
take
and if you actually go to the you know
the community that actually tries to
predict stability there's actually not
consensus on the notion of what
stability it is
you know um as well yeah and so the
question um really comes out
um you know uh so given that instance
how do you actually characterize
stability
right and so you know one way we're
actually approaching this is to say can
we characterize
the variance in someone's sway are the
second order variance in someone's sway
so if you're swaying a lot you know you
know obviously everyone has a certain
amount of sway when they walk if that
variance increases a lot for you then
likely you might fall
and so if we can kind of have a baseline
for your sway and then notice that
increase in that variance
then that can be an indicator that you
might be at risk of falling and that's
what we want to mitigate
and so a quick video i'll show to that
end
really shows
you know what this actually can look
like you know in a particular
environment so we have you know person
walking with the sensor you know walking
through this environment here we have a
depth panorama image that's actually fed
into our network that allows the system
to actually
have a representation of the environment
in addition to the pose that you walked
in
and the goal would be to predict the
person's path
gait and stability um on that trajectory
and we actually have like an active
study that we're doing now um so looking
for participants that would want to
participate
in collecting such a data set
i know i'm coming up on time here um
oh okay cool
okay perfect perfect okay
okay okay perfect
so uh you know on the other side here we
have um external collaborators
right so this is a really a great
project that uh we are working in
collaboration with uh professor dorset
siddique
um uh and my uh uh graduate student
eliang and jd
and so here we have you know uh the goal
of this project is to say you know can
we actually learn from how humans
collaborate together to actually uh uh
to introduce a robotic agent that could
substitute one of these
humans and still perform at a really
high level in terms of
you know the collaborative task
um the pandemic hit and i was very
unfortunate and so we were able to pivot
to an um an online format of this data
collection
that still allowed us to get the
information we needed so in an online
game play scenario if you watch humans
carry you know a table together
virtually and try to avoid obstacles and
perhaps pass through waypoints to a goal
can you actually leverage their force
inputs on that underlying you know
second order dynamics to help you
understand how
the system is expected to evolve and if
you actually observe how humans do that
demonstration if you collect those data
sets can this actually inform you
how the robots are is expected to
perform and then the question becomes
you know which type of modeling
technique is best in terms of behavioral
modeling
as well as world modeling and bringing
those together to be the most effective
in a first order or second order mental
model of your teammate
we're also thinking about ways we can
actually increase the efficiency of
learning from demonstration again
realizing the huge potential that
augmented reality provides us
not only in the task description which
can play a really big role but even in
once you have that information how can
the robot then anticipate the actions of
the
person that it's collaborating with and
sometimes take actions that actually
improve the overall performance of the
team
um even if the uh human may not
particularly be expecting that behavior
so
in a simple example of like carrying a
box
if the human is carrying boxes that are
too heavy for them then the overall team
is at a at a loss because
it's taking longer to transport but if
you actually anticipate that the human
will carry boxes that are too heavy and
the robot steps in and says
i'm going to carry the heavier boxes
and the robot can then uh then the human
can then carry the lighter boxes and
you've increased the the performance
time of the entire team by modeling that
person in real time and anticipating
that to make the overall team better
so uh so lastly the takeaways here
are to be effective collaborators with
humans robots must be able to model
human behavior in their role
there's a significant room for
improvement in robotic hardware for
alternate forms of communication such as
audio visual and tactile
and robot collaborators have the
potential to expand their human
teammates capabilities
enhancing and restoring their quality of
life
thank you very much
[Applause]
hi um i have one question you mentioned
here kind of in your human collaboration
project where you have these different
say robot manipulator arms that you're
manipulating say some common object with
like a human partner
um do you i guess what are your methods
or maybe um sensors that you're using
you mentioned previously how if you have
an environment that's applying an
external torque to your like your uh
built up jacobian for your robot arm you
can actually set parameters for like the
rigidity of your whole system based on
this external forces so typically when
you're applying torques to these you
give it like an electrical signal for it
to know what you want from your control
but do you have ways of actually like um
calculating or receiving what those
torques are on in your individual joints
from like a third a second party like a
human collaborator that's like trying to
push on your robot
it's a fantastic question so quickly
repeating for people online you know
when thinking about like perhaps
physical you know interaction and
collaboration you know what are thoughts
for you know sensors that can actually
get information about forces that are
being applied on the system that may
themselves be indicators of intent and
collaboration
to perform a task so absolutely so
for this particular project you know
we're in a simulation based environment
so we have access to the forces that are
being applied by other agents
but um you know when this evolves to a
more physical scenario you can imagine a
you know yes absolutely leveraging you
know arms for instance that have joint
torque feedback that can give you that
kind of information from points of
contact um and even you know with the
development of our you know new tactile
sensors you can even imagine feeling
some forces even in fingers that could
be for instance in contact with your
environment
but i think you know even kind of
tapping into the bigger question which
you're alluding to which is
you know you know more generically how
can you leverage force external
disturbances
you know in your system you know in
terms of forces to indicate
you know collaboration i think that's a
fantastic you know direction of research
and it changes based on the application
that you're thinking
right um but i think again kind of
looking at what these robots are able to
do in terms of their ability to sense
joint torques you know perhaps fingers
and then even you know work that's
emerging for instance in terms of like
robotic
sensitive skin so you know one word that
comes to mind is like um
work out of professor mark kakulski's
lab where they actually have pneumatic
sensors that they're able to put in
different patches on a robot's
body and then based on that contact
they're able to actually get really
sensitive feedback
from these pneumatic sensors
placed everywhere on the robots
uh external part to actually get that
sort of information so what does robotic
skin look like
you know as you begin to think about
robot safety and
and collaboration so beyond the finger
you know forces you feel and beyond the
internal
joint twerks
what does that contact actually mean i
think that's a very interesting question
any other questions
so one thing i thought was really cool
was the way you
you guys 3d printed some stuff to
calibrate the gel super gel site but i
forgot you call it dense action uh
automatically and it seems throughout
the like oh also what nah okay that's
thomas i know if you're before i ask a
question if you're in the class and you
didn't fill out the thing please fill
out the thing
i've gotten so many emails saying i
forgot to tell the things like fill out
the thing please
um and if you ever attend on zoom you
don't have to fill out the form zoom
takes automatic attendance
sorry
um
i was curious
how you see i mean calibration seems to
be a huge problem in this space
and i'm curious what you see as like
maybe ways to do automatic calibration
where you don't have to necessarily
touch five points or something
um with like a prosthetic or some
augmented reality type of calibration
yeah so uh the question was you know
what's you know
the future of calibration and if i can
kind of narrow that question down to
specifically maybe the tactile sensors
space because of the role that they play
um yeah i think this is you know this is
where we're really resting our hat right
you know these other vision-based
sensors exist
the questions we're asking is from your
design how can you get as much
resolution from that contact as possible
and there are other sensors that have
like really high density points you know
there's some that use like
um
i think it's um dense optical flow where
they actually have like every pixel is a
different thing where they have to
associate some aliasing effect you know
to actually try and catch the
displacement locally on those sensors
so you know yes the million dollar
question is you know hey yes how do you
design the sensor that gives you this
information and account for things like
aliasing and then b the harder part in
my opinion is um then how do you you
know go in to calibrate and model
right these these sensors so for the
shape sensing we think that that's a
really clever way you know to to get a
lot of high density information with the
force information that's just hard right
because again you're dealing with this
high resolution point of contact and if
you actually like kind of think of this
from a continual mechanics standpoint
on the surface you have the normal
the shears and the torsion that you care
about and all of this of course
propagates to the material entire inside
of your sensor right and so how do you
actually you know get as high resolution
for that as you possibly can
as an inherently challenging question so
i mentioned our approach to that which
will
hopefully be wrapping up soon but beyond
that let's say you calibrate one of
these you know again you can imagine you
probably have to have a lot of contacts
to get that to work
so another work that we're hoping to
also have out in the next few few months
uh or sooner um is actually thinking
about a notion of transfer learning so
if you like trained some of these you
know sensors and it took a whole lot of
data to get that
if you've actually replicated to a high
degree
the material shape geometry of a new
sensor
could you actually effectively train a
new calibrated model for that new sensor
with far less
interactions you know based on a
transfer learning approach
so i think you know once we kind of like
solidify some of these techniques
you can imagine you know perhaps
efficiency coming out of you know
methods like that
okay thank you very much
since we have to wrap up the class now
let's again